und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka guten
abend hinter dem erneuten
amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen donald
trump steht auch die sorge wie viel
unheil er in seinen letzten tagen noch
anrichten kann
eines kann er jetzt allerdings nicht
mehr über seinen lieblings medium
twitter zu hetzen
twitter hat ihn dauerhaft gesperrt ein
bemerkenswerter vorgang der aber wieder
ruhe ist noch wirklich moralisch
motiviert wirkt da hätte es in den
vergangenen jahren genügend andere
anlässe gegeben jump und seinem clan den
ton abzudrehen
etwa als sein sohn john junior kürzlich
via twitter einen totalen krieg
propagierte trump erst jetzt zu stoppen
da er seine machtposition verloren hat
dürfte er mit der sorge zu tun haben für
gewaltexzesse wie im capitol mit
verantwortlich gemacht zu werden
ein exzess bei dem fünf menschen ihr
leben verloren ein polizist der von den
anhängern einer ehemals konservativen
law and order partei attackiert wurde
und vier gramm pisten deren wut und wann
bekommen jetzt auch jene zu spüren die
aus reinem machtkalkül mit trump
paktierten benjamin daniel berichtet
scheißkerl verräter menschlicher abfall
so etwas mit einem republikanischen
senator an einem öffentlichen ort
entgegen geschmettert der sich in
letzter minute von trump abgewendet hat
die bilder sind vom reagan national
flughafen trump anhänger bedrängen
lindsey graham der war all die jahre ein
treuer trump basal bis zum sturm auf das
kapitol trump und ich hatten zusammen
einer wahnsinns reise aber jetzt bin ich
raus bild ist wird das dachte man sich
wohl auch bei twitter
nach mehr als 57.000 posts wurde der
wohl meist diskutierte social media
account der welt dauerhaft gesperrt
die begründung von twitter aufgrund der
letzten tweets auf dem account und der
aktuellen umstände sehe man großes
risiko einer weiteren anstiftung zur
gewalt
diese hatte am mittwoch für solche
bilder gesorgt auf einem jetzt
aufgetauchten video ist zu sehen wie
brutal der mob gegen polizisten im
capitol von gi joe biden verurteilt die
täter propaganda seines vorgängers
scharf groß erinnert an goebbels und die
große lüge mann wiederholt sie immer
wieder verankert sie in den köpfen das
hat trump übrigens selbst angekündigt
damals er sagt er wenn ich meine
botschaft nur oft genug wiederholen
glaubt ihr die sperrung des account
kommt laut kritikern viel zu spät jahre
lang sein twitter und co profiteur und
katalysator der radikalen botschaften
gewesen
die art und weise wie die tramgleise aus
miss information gewachsen ist und die
dynamik mit der sich die leute darin
radikalisiert haben sind beispiellos so
etwas haben wir vorher noch nicht erlebt
das wurde zu lange toleriert und das
geht doch nicht nicht im internet und
auch sonst nirgendwo ein hotel würde ja
auch kein treffen in seinen räumen
erlauben bei dem radikale einen
bewaffneten sturm auf das kapitän planen
trump sieht das naturgemäß anders er
postete seine entrüstung schließlich auf
anderen accounts auf die er zugriff hat
darin heißt es tritte habe sich mit den
demokraten abgesprochen und wolle ihn
und 75 millionen großartige patrioten
zum schweigen bringen wie so oft
lieferte er keine belege für seine
aussagen und so wurden auch diese post
mittlerweile gelöscht dennoch us
präsident kündigte an über die gründung
einer eigenen social media plattform
nachzudenken
währenddessen arbeiten nicht nur
demokraten intensiv daran schon
vorzeitig aus dem amt zu entfernen
es schließen sich jetzt auch mehr und
mehr mitglieder der republikanischen
partei an
so fordert nun die erste republikanische
senatorin trumps rücktritt noch vor dem
januar einer zeitung sagte sie ich will
ihn raus haben er hat genug schaden
angerichtet
ein freiwilliger rücktritt trumps ist
unwahrscheinlich sollte es aber
tatsächlich zu einer amtsenthebung
kommen könnte er in zukunft nicht mehr
für ein öffentliches bundesamt
kandidieren das wäre zwar für viele eine
erleichterung die illusion dass das
kapitel jump damit beendet wäre macht
sich allerdings auch keiner
kaum ein land hat eine so drastische
maßnahmen gegen kuwait 19 verhängt wie
china
erklärtes ziel war es die infektionen
auf fast null herunter zu bringen was
auch weitgehend gelang in bous ein
mutmaßlicher ursprungsort der ganzen
plage darf die jugend inzwischen sogar
wieder große techno partys feiern
im demokratisch regierten neuseeland ist
das übrigens auch gelungen die methoden
waren nicht so martialisch aber nicht
weniger konsequent auch die neuseeländer
leben längst wieder eine normalität von
der wir nur träumen können
die strategie funktioniert aber nur bei
streng kontrollierten
einreisebestimmungen und wenn jeder neu
auftreten der infektionsherd sofort
ausgetreten wird und so geschieht es
jetzt wieder in china mit der dort
üblichen drastik stephanie schöneborn
berichtet sie nennen es das zweite buch
die elf millionen stadt chittagong heute
schließen u-bahnhöfe keine öffentlichen
verkehrsmittel dürfen mehr fahren
in zwei städten direkt vor den toren
pekings wurde das kriegsrecht verhängt
in den sozialen medien berichten leute
aus vororten über den lockdown der fast
über nacht kam die letzten tage durften
nämlich zur arbeit gehen wie durfte
nicht rausgehen mussten drei tage warten
um den zweiten krone test zu machen
die kinder durften nicht zur schule
gehen jetzt müssen wir warten bis wir
weitere tests machen wie die schulen
dann entscheiden müssen china hat angst
und die maßnahmen sind radikal schnell
mit einem ziel 0 infektionen straßen
werden desinfiziert insgesamt 18
millionen menschen im lockdown weil es
mehr als 20 neue infektionen am tag gab
in einem anderen vor ort wird per
lautsprecher verkündet bleiben sie zu
hause gehen sie nicht raus leute vom
krankenhaus kommen und machen corona
tests mit euch niemand wird ausgelacht
die menschen kaufen kiloweise mehl reis
und eier da die orte teils über nacht zu
gesperrt wurden und niemand weiß wann
der locker und vorbei sein wird
außer zum einkaufen muss jeder in
strenge quarantäne zehn tage zu hause
bleiben
tausende medizinische helfer führten
innerhalb von drei tagen massentest
durch in speziellen labor zelten werden
die tests ausgewertet
heute verkündet das chinesische
staatsfernsehen
die zahlen würden wieder sinken
politisch ist dieser neue ausbruch
brisant skijumping hat einen volkskrieg
gegen das virus ausgerufen und im
september mit ehrenmedaillen den sieg
über das virus gefeiert nachdem es nach
offiziellen angaben keine neuinfektionen
mehr in china gab
dies stellt eine weitere heldentat in
der geschichte des kampfes der
menschheit gegen das virus
chinas volkskrieg gegen das virus geht
weiter auch bei den impfungen 50
millionen menschen sollen bis zum
chinesischen neujahrsfest mitte februar
geimpft werden
normalerweise beginnt dann die große
reisewelle dieses jahr fordert die
regierung auf nicht zu reisen und mit
den aktuellen deutschen corona zahlen
beginnen jetzt die nachrichten von heinz
wolf wobei das robert koch institut
davon ausgeht dass wegen der feiertage
die daten frühestens kommende woche
wieder belastbar sein werden die zahlen
das rkw registrierte knapp 24.700
neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
zudem wurden 1083 neue todesfälle in
verbindung mit cupid 19 gemeldet geimpft
wurden mehr als eine halbe million
menschen bundesweit beim thema impfungen
geht der streit innerhalb der großen
koalition weiter
spd-generalsekretär klingbeil
kritisierte erneut gesundheitsminister
sparen gegenüber der frankfurter
allgemeinen sonntagszeitung hielt
ersparen versäumnisse bei der
vorbereitung vor cdu-chefin kramp
karrenbauer warf der spd
laut saarbrücker zeitung vor inmitten
der pandemie
mit der debatte um das impfen wahlkampf
zu machen in indonesien wird ein
passagierflugzeug mit 62 menschen an
bord vermisst die behörden befürchten
dass die maschine ins meer gestürzt ist
vor der insel java wurden trümmerteile
entdeckt schon kurz nach dem start war
der kontakt zu dem flugzeug abgerissen
das auf dem weg nach pontiac auf der
insel borneo war offenbar verlor die
maschine in weniger als einer minute
knapp 3000 meter höhe warum ist noch
unklar
anderthalb wochen vor der amtseinführung
des neu gewählten us präsidenten beiden
hat nordkorea die usa als größten feind
des landes bezeichnet zugleich kündigte
machthaber kim jong un bei einem
kongress der kommunistischen partei den
ausbau des atomwaffenprogramms an neue
raketen würden getestet die pläne für
ein atom u boot seien bereits
abgeschlossen
in teilen spaniens hat ein sturmtief zu
einem winter chaos geführt mindestens
drei menschen kamen ums leben
mit am stärksten betroffen von den
schneefällen war die region madrid in
der spanischen hauptstadt lag so viel
schnee wie seit jahrzehnten nicht mehr
im straßen- bahn- und luftverkehr kam es
zu massiven behinderungen schnee her
auch bei uns in den so genannten höheren
lagen und natürlich will man daraus
spazierengehen snowboarden rodeln mit
den kindern
problematisch für das in dem moment wo
alle an dieselben stellen wollen und
sich dort dann virus gerecht knobeln
sowie das kürzlich in winterberg im
sauerland war ein solcher ansturm sollte
in den deutschen wintersportgebieten an
diesem wochenende verhindert werden die
meisten wurden abgeriegelt
das war eigentlich auch hinlänglich
kommuniziert trotzdem machten sich viele
auf den weg es wenn klaus berichtet
wenn es beim aufstieg in den schwarzwald
so aussieht dann ist viel los
zu viel für diese tage dass sie an der
schwarzwaldhochstraße dazu führt dass
die polizei für autos schon am vormittag
dicht macht
das wiederum die frage aufwirft ob die
appelle der politik auf ausflüge in oft
weit entfernte schnee gebiete zu
verzichten überhaupt gehört werden
den eindruck aber bisher so leider nicht
also ich selbst habe jetzt die hoffnung
gehabt dass durch die schneefälle es hat
jetzt weit runter schneit dass die
menschen jetzt daheim bleiben weil sie
ja unter im tal zum teil schlittenfahrer
könnte aber bislang könne man das nicht
bestätigen also wie gesagt es war ja
selbst am samstagmorgen um 9 uhr 30
schon alles zu weil oben schon alle
parkplätze voll waren
doch weil dann von unten erst mal
niemand nach kommt bleibt es boden heute
relativ entspannt genügend platz um
abstand halten zu können
ein anderes bild also als am vergangenen
wochenende als es auf der straße zum
verkehrschaos kam als auf pisten
abstandsregeln oft nicht eingehalten
wurden die sperrungen haben das heute
verhindert sorgen aber auch für unmut
es ärgert uns einfach dass mir als baden
partner hier nur nicht einmal zehn
kilometer fahren dürfen unseren sport zu
machen und weiß gott komme sowohl her
also irgendwo ist es einfach nicht
akzeptabel
sperrungen heute auch rund um den großen
feldberg im taunus in hessen schon viele
kilometer davor sind die zufahrtsstraßen
für ausflügler zu auch hier ist es am
berg ruhiger als zuletzt
viele straßen sollen noch mindestens bis
montag komplett gesperrt bleiben
wegen schneebruchgefahr und krone und
dann ich glaube es wird eine gewisse
vernunft jetzt ein kennen die ferien
sind vorbei und ich glaube wenn die
neuigkeit des schnees dann auch so ein
bisschen schon schnee von gestern es
dann wird es auch weniger in baden
württemberg wird sich der
ministerpräsident in sachen schnee
ausflüge nicht allein aufs hoffen
verlassen
die menschen müssen wissen dass wir sie
wieder nach hause schicken wenn es
beispielsweise im schwarzwald oder auf
der schwäbischen alb einfach zu voll
wird
restriktion stadt appell heute scheint
dass vielerorts funktioniert zu haben
die plastikmüll exporte aus deutschland
sind 2020 im vergleich zum vorjahr um
zehn prozent gesunken so die schätzung
des bundesverbands der deutschen
entsorgungswirtschaft
demnach wurden im vergangenen jahr 900
86.000 tonnen kunststoffabfall ins
ausland transportiert das entspricht
knapp einem sechstel der ist hierzulande
anfallenden plastikmülls größter
abnehmer ist malaysia gefolgt von den
niederlanden und der türkei
und jetzt die lottozahlen dieses samstag
sie lauten wie immer ohne gewähr
7 16 19 20 30 41 superzahl 5 und weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf de und im zdf text auf seite 5 56
und jetzt noch die wetteraussichten für
morgen im süden scheint nach einem teils
nebligen start auf die sonne im norden
gibt es mehr wolken und am nachmittag
kommt von der nordsee her regen auf
die temperatur steigt auf werte von
minus fünf bis plus vier grad
am montag ist es ähnlich ab dienstag
wird es wieder überall unbeständiger und
vor allem im süden auch milder so viele
von uns an diesem samstagabend weiter
geht es im aktuellen sportstudio und
danach so gegen 0.25 gibt es die nächste
rate express ich es morgen wieder sehen
[Musik]